I'm laureles with I am the Secretary
General of the Council of women world
leaders and the question that I would
like to answer because I think it's very
important which is the one about growth
and what do I see is a distinguishing
strength of Latin America and how this
strength will help increase growth and
impact development to me the incredible
strength of this region is its energy as
you long as it's real dedication to
wanting to improve the region everyone
here at the World Economic Forum is very
dedicated to wanting to see Latin
America cosa succede you wanted it to be
a real competitive player in the
marketplace and to ensure that the
challenges that the region face are
going to be overcome the region has done
some excellent work in terms of
financial stability in terms of some of
the removal quiggle out of motor poverty
helping improve the health of women in
pearls and the education level of women
girls I think there's a great vitality
here in this region and a great desire
to find solutions and best practices and
to be very open to the ideas of others
going to be very curious about the ideas
of others I find that energy to be
something that I think is going to help
carry this region to leapfrog their
progress and to make a major
contribution globally